[Music]
[Music]
i've managed to have an experience that
no actor gets they have
[Music]
i hope will give the audience something
really
tangible that they can hang on as this
thriller rattles along
[Music]
[Music]
who wishes he could be here but he can't
be here today
[Music]
when i looked at his cabin
i could see his clothes were still in
there his bag was still in there
we continue to interview everybody who
has come into contact with your son
i understand that you've been traveling
a great deal
you've been in libya
iraq
you have recently believed it is because
of what i do that ethan is missing
now mr murray i have to tell you that we
are investigating every hypothesis
including kidnapping
would you say your work was dangerous
have you even thought
was on father you've been to your son i
know about that i know i'm never here
but i think i found something just have
a look at this
[Music]
at two o'clock
i get a call from this man he's higher
up than anybody in the police force they
asked me to come off this case
you're on your own mr murray
you know what's been going on here you
know the cops came into the office
they've got the computers they've got
the hard drives they've got the iraq
files
[Music]
tell me what i want to know
[Music]
you